a lot of times you look at these
injuries like Kobe wasn't doing anything
that was really strenuous Dan Marino
wasn't doing anything David Beckham
wasn't doing anything strenuous he was
you know they're barely moving and all
of a sudden it just goes and I don't
know if it's just the accumulation of
miles on that it's the timing of it the
fact you had a calf injury where you
favor in the calf injury does that make
the Achilles weaker and that's why we
reached out to a doctor Marc addicts he
is a former NFL player and part of
DIRECTV's fantasy zone he's an
orthopedic surgeon and I know we're
gonna talk in generalities Marc because
you know you've dealt with this but you
don't know about Kevin's injury so in
fairness to the medical community we'll
talk in generalities about this
so explain and thanks for joining us doc
what is an Achilles tear what happens so
you know all of your cast muscles are
going down to back your leg and they
join together in a confluence and that's
what the Achilles tendon is it's it's
basically the tendon of all of your calf
muscles to give you the strength to go
up onto your toes and to push off and
jump and accelerate and and the Achilles
generally ruptures right in the center
of the tendon right so when you when you
open it up and look at it it looks like
a bunch of spaghetti on each end it's
not like it rips off the bone it's not
like it rips out of the muscle it
generally just ruptures right in in half
and you were making reference to the
fact that guys were injured not doing
much generally it means in these
athletes they'll just get chronic
inflammation that is in the tendon and
the most athletes have it in their
Achilles in their patellar tendon in the
quad and then and then eventually
something happens in some guys when they
move just the right way at just the
wrong time which is what happened with
Kevin is there any connection obviously
there is a medical connection with you
know the calf to the Achilles but the
fact if you have a tender calf muscle
can that maybe exacerbate the Achilles
well right so when when he injured it
the first time the one thing that that
really struck me is the fact that he was
jogging down the court really and he
looked behind him kind of angrily like
someone had hit him and we heard the the
airforce officer talking about where it
felt like someone hit him in the back of
the leg with a 2x4 so I knew something
tore then but where he grabbed his leg
was what more on the calf muscle but it
could have been sort of where the muscle
is meeting the Achilles tendon and it
was caused initially by a little bit of
chronic inflammation both within that
within that muscular 10-minutes
attachment where the muscle meet the
tendon and with a in the tendon itself
so you know are they connected honestly
a calf strain should make it so you're
not pushing off quite as hard so if
anything it should be protective
um you kill each tendon but at the same
time it can alter your bomb mechanics
but but I think it's more that there was
a little bit of chronic inflammation
with that tended to begin with and
honestly since it tore it might be a
good thing it might have been something
that lingered throughout the offseason
and then tore next year and so now that
it's done he'll get fixed and he'll
he'll be back and ready to go and
obviously that's assuming that it's torn
which is my opinion have using at the
video have you done this type of surgery
I have I mean now in my practice I do I
don't but I mean I did earlier in my
career and during training did a lot of
these but everybody sub specializes
particularly in the sports world and so
I work on more the large joints but that
being said I mean I've seen this injury
repaired a bunch of times and I'm also
familiar with the literature and in
professional athletes you know honestly
about two-thirds of the guys are able to
return to sport right and and the
timetable to return is usually in the
ten to twelve month window so given that
this is happening during the NBA Finals
is really problematic for his return
even next season provided this is a
complete rupture of the Achilles tendon
and I've seen the video and I've seen
the video in slow motion and he's
pushing off that that right foot and you
really do see this this this ripple
throughout his entire calf musculature
which honestly I will be
shocked if it's not a complete killing
ruptured yeah you can watch that kind of
roll up that's what happens with the
Achilles and having witness this you
just see it roll up and you know
somebody feels like they've been shot in
the in the back of the leg if you do you
want to hear about all my surgeries doc
I do anything I can offer you then be
helpful would be would be a pleasure
what's the most surgeries you've ever
done in a day eleven how does that work
only do it I'm only doing six today so
okay I know we we pulled you out of
surgery hopefully there's there's nobody
who's waiting for you to come back we're
good I mentioned that I had
microfracture surgery this is years ago
and you know where they're drilling
holes in your knees and trying to see if
there's blood flow and you know can you
get cartilage to grow I was told that
that was really hard to come back from
for professional athletes the
microfracture surgery is there something
that's more difficult where you just see
where it's sort of vague if you're going
to come back and be able to play because
Amar'e Stoudemire had this you know some
basketball players have had it but the
microfracture I was told is you know
pretty serious to try to come back and
play at a high level well if I had to
pick one thing not to have it would be
microfracture surgery and the reason is
is the cartilage that covers the ends of
your bones right the smooth white shiny
stuff that you see on the end of a
chicken leg that cartilage is is
articulating against the same cartilage
on the other side of the joint right so
you have it on one side of your knee on
the femur of your thigh bone the other
side of your knee on the tibia and when
it's normal the coefficient of friction
is less than ice against ice but once
that cartilage is worn off which wasn't
you what you're trying to do is recreate
more privilege but you only have so much
and sometimes that microfracture surgery
does not get cartilage to grow and and
what that what you have the reason they
do the micro fracture is you have
osteoarthritis right yeah everything
else that you care you can fix you
really can't fix cartilage you're hoping
you get some cartilage to grow but it's
never as good as what was there that's
why we see
athletes that have microfracture tend to
you know they're kind of got one foot
out the door at that point yeah the
doctor that I had famous doctor in the
Bay Area he wanted to grow cartilage in
a petri dish and this is probably 25
years ago and I was like I was totally
cutting-edge yes and he said hey there
the growing cartilage in a petri dish in
like Sweden or Denmark or something he
goes are you interested in this I said
doc I just want to be able to walk
comfortably I'm not I don't want to have
cartilage inserted in me but you know
the medical community and you know all
the different surgeries there but you
know an Achilles hasn't we haven't moved
up the timetable with Achilles surgery
in rehab right it's it's it's usually
been around a year I mean it generally
is continued return at six months it's
possible right it's possible but when
you look when you look at the studies of
professional athletes usually that that
window that they return to form is 10 to
12 months and in the NBA I mean we've
seen Toby come back we've seen Dominique
Wilkins come back but a lot of guys
their their their level of play really
fell off after this injury I think Kevin
is going to fall into the Rico be in the
Dominic Wilkins category not the act and
I'm not the category guys fall off
performance-wise but nevertheless it's
it's a long recovery when's the last
time you operated on the wrong knee
think it can't it will so I'm checking
all the time but but you guys doctors
make I decide to put my initials on the
knee that I was getting cut on that's
right so you gave me a sharpie you
didn't but the doc goes you write your
initials on the knee and I go god this
guy don't even know which knee is
bothering it was was he was protecting
himself to say you your initials right
that's the knee I'm cutting on right and
that's what happened yeah so I have my
patient right there and they suppose I
write my initials and I trust mine more
because I've looked through the chart
and I you know I honestly but know I've
heard the sort
I mean it does happen so it's and
honestly even if you and I both put our
initials on the wrong leg and I operated
on it you're still getting paid so yeah
it's it's it's serious business
I can't imagine you going to a party
where somebody finds out what you do and
they go hey can I pull down my pants and
you look at this here my bad my bad
Thank You doc we appreciate your time as
always that's dr. mark addicts
orthopedic surgeon former NFL lineman
and part of DIRECTV's fantasies though
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]